- It's real simple,
more money more problems,
more people more energy.
("Goat Life Anthem" by Jan Ace)
So here in Ft. Lauderdale to
give a speech tomorrow morning
and the package we put
together with the organizers
was to do a dinner before,
and I'm doing one in Denver as well.
We'll be doing it in D.C. and Arizona
later in the year, right?
And one other place, I think.
- [Tyler] California, P.D.
- Oh right, got it and
a bunch of (mumbling).
So a lot of fun,
three, four, five, seven, nine, 10, 12,
depending on each market, I
think this one's three or four.
And so we're excited for it,
it should be a lot of fun.
It's a good book you're reading.
- Yes, it is.
- How are you?
- Good, I'm good.
- Nice to meet you.
Want me to sign it for you?
- Yes, please.
Yeah this is that.
- That's exactly what you
should be doing during,
(mumbling).
- One, yeah.
- Thanks for reading it, man.
- Wow, (mumbling).
- Thank you, thanks for reading it.
That's very nice.
That was cool.
(mumbling)
Thank you, thank you.
- I live up north of here a little bit
for about nine years.
I have offices all over the country.
I drove over from Naples today.
- Is that where you live?
- I got peoples lined up
for the event tomorrow
all over the country.
No, I don't live there, though.
Now I live out in Phoenix,
I call Phoenix and my
corporate headquarters home.
- I see.
- I used to live up the
street here a little bit.
- Very nice.
- For about nine years.
- Kristen Reardon, nice to meet you.
- Hey Kristen, Gary Vaynerchuk.
Hey brother.
- Joseph Supena, how are ya?
Nice to see you.
- Real pleasure.
Are you kidding?
Thrilled to be here.
Well cheers, guys.
Thank you so much for joining me.
Cheers.
- For sure, thank you.
So, here's the thing with me.
So for my company we'll
do, projected right now,
to do a little over and
I've been struggling
with going past that.
My next goal is.
- Let's start there before
we go anywhere else.
You gotta agree with me that
that's completely arbitrary.
It just seems like the next
logical, exciting place to go.
- That's what I want.
- Which is fine.
- You like the carat of it.
I get it.
Okay, go ahead.
- For me to get there, I feel like,
and the last few years
I've hired a couple COOs
that I thought were the ones.
- Right, you thought
you were gonna bring in
the mature person that's gonna take you
to that next place.
- Not even mature, just thought they
fit all the prerequisites.
- What were the prerequisites?
- Knowledge level, want to, biggest thing.
It's a fucking commitment.
And I get that.
That's the biggest struggle
is it's not their company.
So they're not gonna have that same,
or it's hard for me to find that guy.
But I like to bring up from within,
guys that come through
the ranks, you know.
But all the top salesmen and managers
that I have currently,
they're just all missing that...
- Well, there's a couple things.
One of the first things I
think I really taught my dad,
when I think about my life,
about teaching my dad stuff,
which is always weird and interesting,
I just remember this very clearly.
I think one of the things that,
especially my dad and you
have a lot of similarities.
My dad came from dick shit.
He came to America when
he was 23 years old.
Live in, I mean, my mom and dad both lived
in an environment where their whole lives
they grew up where the
bathroom was outside.
Soviet Russia was no joke.
You'll never find anybody that cares about
it the way you do.
- I get that part.
- And you need to--
- But there's other companies out there
that have COOs that will fill my chore
so I can grow up.
- There's other companies that have COOs,
but you're the judge and jury of your COO.
And you need to decide
and spend some time on
are you holding them too accountable?
Are you looking for something
that's not achievable?
And by the way, you may or may not.
I have no idea who these
one or two or three people have been.
But I think one of the biggest
things that entrepreneurs
struggle with is calibrating
number twos, threes, and fours.
When you scale.
And the deltas are all over the place.
It's interesting to me what I think about
my dad, my brother, how I think about
what I expected from them.
I would tell you that my shortcoming
is I don't expect enough.
If you look at my world,
one of the reasons I'm so happy
and I am who I am, and
the reason that I always
try to talk to myself is
why I can be very cynical
and regretful and resentful
in my 70s and 80s is I
actually navigate through life
having no expectations of others at all.
Which is an incredible
formula for the short term.
I'm 42 years old, I've
struggled to be upset.
What I'm very acutely aware of
is when I'm 70, 60, 80, I'm gonna be like
fuck everybody else
because I've made deals
that aren't as good for
me because I'm the AAA
and, you know, I'm
okay, I just don't have.
And so I think calibrating
your expectations is important.
And I'll give you another
thing to think a lot about.
One thing that's been fascinating to me,
and I appreciate you bringing up ego,
another thing I've seen a lot of
is people that have come from nothing
and have built something substantial,
play a game with themselves
that they need reinforcement.
I do it at times, that
they need reinforcement
for themselves around how good they are.
And so one of the things
I would think a lot about,
one of the things I think I've done well,
and continue to try to strive for,
is your best case scenario
is your number two,
she or he needs to do all the things
that you don't want to or you are now
at a point of being 40 know
that you're not as good at.
And I think one thing
I've watched a lot of
number ones do in family
business and small businesses
and mid-sized businesses
they've built from scratch
is hire people who are just Bs to their A
on the same skillset
and they don't realize
the reason they're
frustrated is what they need
is somebody who's completely
doing something else.
Those are things that I think you need to
be thinking about.
Alright, I gotta go.
(mumbling)
So fun.
Great to see you again.
(mumbling)
Angles.
Got it?
(mellow music)
Thank you.
How you doing?
Good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- How are you?
- Fine.
I met you with Alex.
- I remember, I remember.
- In your office.
I'm very happy to see you.
- I'm glad we made this work.
- Yes.
And here I am with, hi.
(laughing)
Here I am with a lot of influencers.
(mumbling) all of that.
- Yeah, let's hang out.
Here's my thing, and I
just got out of a dinner,
the number one thing that
everybody in this room
should hope for is that your competitors
spend time worrying about you.
(laughing)
- That's true.
- Something changed.
- People sometimes take
it's because of ego
that I don't know
anything about people that
I'm competing with, it's not that,
it's just that I'm more worried
about my audience than what,
you know what I think people struggle with
is how much abundance there is.
There's nothing anybody here can do
that's taking away from somebody else.
If you're good enough, you will
get everything that you want
because there's so much.
There's so much money,
there's so much attention,
there's so much opportunity,
there's so much exposure.
There's nothing a buff, whatever you do,
whatever I do, all 50
people that do what I do,
aren't taking away from me.
And people think they are.
People spend so much time
looking at somebody else's post,
they got more likes, they're
selling more product,
they're on TV, and it's just not smart.
So respect what people think about me.
I respect it, I do.
But I don't let it dictate what I do,
and I don't spend time on it.
- That's one big thing I learned from you.
And I always used to wear
suit and tie, and all that.
- Yes, look the part.
- But this doesn't connect-
- With who you actually are.
- Me.
- Yeah, I, you know it's funny,
I make fun of people, I
don't make fun of them,
I push back on the culture
of watches and Lamborghinis
and this, and I have a friend, Andy,
who really loves Lamborghinis,
and I had a great talk with him, I'm like,
I believe in that.
If it's really your passion, great.
I don't believe in getting the car
to make yourself look
cool to get the girl,
or to sell people your course.
I just believe in the truth.
If you truly love watches,
or you truly love wearing,
I have friends who love
wearing a suit everyday,
and they're just as right as I am
for not wearing a suit everyday.
It just has to be your truth.
- Yeah.
And if your purpose is
changing people's lives,
you have to commit to them
with that kind of language,
that kind of attention.
- That's where you're at.
Awesome, yeah.
- Okay, I'm Michelle Lewin.
I'm from Venezuela, fitness model.
I'm working with the social media,
like Instagram, Facebook.
Actually in the beginning,
I just talked like a normal person,
posting video about family,
dogs, travels and the same.
But after I saw the people interested
about the video for workout videos.
I so I posting videos,
posting tips, you know.
(mumbling) social media.
Actually I was, I think,
was the first person to show
on social media, their body
tiny, muscle definition,
but not too muscle, not so, how you say?
- [Woman] Masculine.
- Too masculine.
So always all the time, I
posting in two languages,
in Spanish and English,
so my audience is most in United States,
and that's the reason why, you know.
- The difference in your (mumbling).
- Yeah.
- The incomes.
They're different.
- Yeah.
So--
- You live where?
- I live here.
- In Miami?
- In Southbridge, yeah.
Um...
- When did you move here?
- Five years ago.
But I live in Venezuela go
to Europe nine years ago,
because I married Jimmy.
We try in Italy, in Spain,
for work, to find work,
but I don't have luck.
- So you guys moved from
Venezuela to Italy and then Spain
and then the U.S.?
- And then the U.S..
- Yeah, we ended up here.
- The thing is, that's exactly right.
Back to what you and I
connect on, back to optimism,
the internet is the platform.
And so whether you started as number one
or number one billion,
it's all gonna end up in the same place.
By the way, there's strengths
and weaknesses in both.
There's advantages and disadvantages.
They think I'm better, when you say,
"Oh, that person's a piece
of shit," that's dangerous.
But when you don't dwell
on it and focus on it,
and you focus on the
positive, that's different.
It's a very fine line.
- One thing that amazed me is that
your kindness that you're always
talking about, to be kind,
it's not about you, all
your team is very kind.
- Because I'll fire them if they're not.
(laughing)
I mean it.
- Yeah, it's important.
- I mean it, like I'm in control.
If they weren't kind, if I
was kind and they weren't,
then I'd be delirious or
delusional or a bad operator.
Babin will tell you that
it's just unacceptable.
I don't even know what else to say.
Not being kind is like,
I would argue VaynerMedia's
biggest problem
is the other way.
People are not giving critical feedback
because everyone's trying to be too nice,
and then we've gone too far,
like I've spent the last year because,
people were getting fired
and they were shocked
because nobody was giving them feedback
because we were over indexing on kindness.
- Yes, too much kindness.
- Which everything is, there's
a great Russian saying,
(speaking in foreign language)
It translates into everything's at
its best when it's balanced.
But I will tell you as somebody
who believes this very much,
I would much rather be
on the side of over-kind,
if that's my weakness,
that's something I'm willing to live with.
Yeah, so nice meeting you guys.
My friend, so nice to meet you,
so nice to meet you.
Good luck, good luck.
- It was a pleasure.
- Such a pleasure.
(mumbling)
(camera clicking)
(mellow music)
- [Man] My partner, Matt.
You didn't get to meet him last time.
- Yeah, good to see you, brother.
- Where do you want us?
- Anywhere's fine.
What are we, just two weeks around?
- Now we're nine days out.
- That's crazy.
- I genuinely think you guys are sitting
on something extremely big.
I think the key now is,
it's the same old shit,
when hustlers and youngsters,
fresh eyes are good eyes.
When you don't know what
the fuck you're doing,
you're actually doing it for
the sake of making it work.
I think when you get deeper in the game,
then people are chirping in your ear,
and just like, with more
attention comes more opinions.
Nobody was giving you opinions
because nobody gives a fuck
about what you were doing.
- And we thought were gonna do it,
and they thought we were gonna fail.
- We tried to put up this
impenetrable force that's like,
yo, we've been doing this.
- I'm the same way.
I totally get it, I think it's right.
I think it's right.
And on that is then
having the equal balance
of ego and humility.
The ego of we did this, we figured out,
like fuck you, is right,
and then having the humility of like,
what pieces, now that you
understand it a little bit,
now that you've seen it,
what doesn't come as natural,
what isn't as interesting to do,
what is a little bit
murkier than you'd like it.
Having that humility's important.
And then just figuring out what it is.
- It's been a huge
learning process for us.
Delegating tasks, learning to trust people
with the job you hired
them to do and stuff.
- Understanding that
an 86 by somebody else
is better than your 100
because a thousand 86s
is better than four 100s.
People struggle with that shit.
I'm looking for 86s.
And everybody wants, you know,
some fucking founders are
stupid, they want 110.
And I'm always like,
motherfucker why would somebody
care about your child more than you?
Just it's audacity, it's ego, it's stupid.
And then others are looking for 100
just 'cause they like
perfection or they're more anal
or type A, and I respect that,
but that's a flaw for scale.
That's great for art.
- I think from my angle,
when I look at employees,
I look at just being able to hold them
and not having them have bad habits,
and if they understand
me and they understand
what I would do in a situation,
and the more time they spend with me,
the more I rub off on them.
- I think that's right,
as long as you understand,
to me it's defining bad
habits and deathblows.
My big thing is deathblows.
Just don't get caught on these six things,
and then if number seven through 88
is not exactly like me, then that's cool,
'cause otherwise you wouldn't
be my employee, you'd be me.
I have to run.
- Good man, thank you, appreciate it.
- Yeah, wish you guys well.
Morning vlog, from Ft. Lauderdale.
Super excited about the meeting I just had
with the Rolling Loud guys,
putting together one of
the real impressive kind of
music festivals.
And now I'm heading to the event,
looking forward to the keynote,
and now I'm gonna answer a question,
'cause that's what we do in the back seat.
Backseat answers.
The BSA.
- [Babin] Question from Nick.
How does one keep the macro goal
and not change it while
still changing in the micro?
I'm struggling with my macro goal!
- Well, that means you haven't
defined your macro goal.
You know, I mean, you don't change,
the micro goals are a hell of a lot easier
and worthwhile debating and changing.
The macro goals should
never, ever, ever change.
For me the ambition of the process
of trying to buy the New York Jets
is my macro professional goal.
The ambition to be the
greatest entrepreneur
in this great entrepreneur
era in our society
is my macro goal, those two things.
That's where I'm at.
And honestly only the chase of the Jets
was my true first macro goal.
I've added this as I'm
like, wait a minute,
I'm not gonna make the most money,
but I can provide the most
value for entrepreneurs
in this 20 year era
as a nice a addition,
but I didn't change the other macro goal.
I think you can only
have a black and white
and a gray goal, I think
the black and white
is the chase of buying the New York Jets,
the ambition to buy, and I think the gray,
the more, you know, I
think there's a good,
selfish and selfless way
to think about things
on the macro, but to answer
your question directly,
you just haven't defined your macro goal.
You can change your, your
macro goal's your macro goal.
I wanna be a good man,
I wanna cure cancer,
I wanna buy a home in
Jamaica for my mother.
You know, big goals that you
shouldn't really, really change.
Or at least if you're lucky
enough to have achieved them,
and lucky's the wrong word,
if you've been able to achieve them,
and/or if you underestimated
how much you had in you
and your original macro
goal ended up being smaller,
I think adding to it, I
would argue that's me.
I would argue that my
ambition for the chase
of buying the Jets was obvious and
has been in place forever,
I didn't think about trying
to make the biggest impact
as an entrepreneur and to
entrepreneurs in this era.
I've added that.
I think that's even, not loftier,
but it's a gray to the black and white.
Nonetheless, I think you need
to try to stretch yourself,
and really understand your macro.
To me the chase is my macro.
And I put that into the bucket of,
hey I'm frustrated I
haven't won any Superbowls,
lemme take care of it myself.
No I can just, you can send me that way.
And he's right there.
(mumbling)
(crowd cheering)
- Great crowd.
- Yeah, it sounded like it.
I heard the roar as you were coming on.
- It was an awful crowd,
I turned 'em around.
(laughing)
It was all me, man.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
- It's a pleasure.
- I've never heard you speak.
I'd love to come sometime.
- Thank you, yeah.
- Where do you go after this?
- I'm in Philly tomorrow,
and then I have Denver, I
have several with these guys.
- Oh, you're doing the one in Denver,
I'm doing the one in Denver.
- Good, so maybe we can
spend a little time.
- You gotta get me a book.
- Okay, sure.
- I gotta get you to sign me a book.
- Sure, lemme, can you find one, Babin?
So excited.
Can I steal your pen real quick?
Thank you.
I was in the greenroom, thank
you so much, thanks, Robert.
- I'm Johnny (mumbling).
- He's a beast.
Robert, take care.
I'll give you a very good piece of advice,
and this is actually me
giving myself some advice,
the number one, not the
number, one of the easily
three biggest mistakes I'm making
is not repeating my most viral content
over and over and over again.
Stg I'm starting to realize
with my content is like
wait a minute, I'm like Bon Jovi.
I need to play the greatest hits.
It's already proven that it's worked.
Back to more, more, more.
I see a 100 million views
or two million views or
500,000 shares and I'm
like, fuck, I nailed it.
What I'm trying to understand
is like wait a minute,
fucking Facebook's, it's everybody.
Seven billion fucking people,
four billion, whatever.
It's like I need to keep playing,
so I would tell you if you
leave with anything even
tactical today, whatever was
your best piece of content,
literally repost it
tomorrow, just post it again.
Watch what happens.
Fascinating.
Stg I'm starting to
think a lot more about.
(writing)
Thanks for coming.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- You're welcome, bro.
See you soon.
Thank you so much, bye bye.
(mumbling)
- [Man] Gary!
My man!
Thank you for everything!
- Thanks for coming.
You're welcome brother.
One thing that connects all of us,
whether you're an entrepreneur,
whether you work somewhere,
whether you're devastated,
the one thing that connects all of us
is that for us to take the step
in what we're trying to achieve,
whether it's financial,
whether it's legacy,
whatever it may be, the
one thing that connects us
is we have to trade on attention.
The thing that I desperately want
everybody to leave this talk with
is understanding that attention
is just like real estate.
And that attention
is the gateway drug to
everything you want, period.
Before you can tell me how great you are,
how awesome what you're selling is,
you need my attention.
Before you can tell me
anything, you need my attention.
What everybody in this room
needs to wrap their head around
is that this device owns the
attention of our society.
You may be upset about it,
you might be sad that when you go out
people aren't talking to each other.
You can do whatever the fuck you want,
it doesn't change the fact that this
has the attention.
And if you are sitting in this room today
and you have not figured out how to put
written words, audio, or
video into the platforms
that sit on top of this, you
are fundamentally irrelevant.
Now what you're doing with
your allocation of content,
and ad spend on Facebook and Instagram
is the same thing that
happens in real estate
when somebody knows they need to buy
or debated to buy something
in a hot up and coming area,
they don't.
Their friends did.
It went up.
It happened.
Then they get sad, they get
another chance to invest
for $150,000 more, but
because they fucked up
and passed at $150,000
less, they say no again,
six months later it keeps blowing up,
now it's up $300,000.
Now you're like fuck again.
'Cause you passed twice.
This is the story of Uber for me.
I passed on Uber's angel round twice.
Twice.
How many people read or have
Crush It, my first book?
If you go back and look at it,
I acknowledge in the acknowledgements,
I thank my family and one
random person, Travis,
the cofounder of Uber.
I passed on my one of my best
business friend's startup twice
at a $4 million valuation,
and he was one of my best buds,
and it went on to become Uber.
I was writing $25,000 and
$50,000 checks back then.
If I wrote one of my normal
checks back then into Uber,
that investment would
have paid me $400 million.
(crowd grumbling)
I'm not sad.
(crowd laughing)
I'm not.
I'm being dead serious.
I don't give a fuck about the money.
I give a fuck about the
freedom of playing the game.
Understand if you're a true bred
entrepreneur in this audience,
you're not in it for the money,
you're in it for the game.
I actually love that I
passed on Uber twice.
(crowd cheering)
I'm being serious.
The quickest tell for me in five minutes
when I hang with somebody,
if they're a true bred
or if they're not is are
they in it for the game
or do they wanna buy a watch.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you so much.
(crowd yelling)
- Alright, I gotta go, sorry.
Love you.
(crowd cheering)
(kissing)
- [Man] So my question to
you really evolves around
the idea of being young
and wanting to really do my own thing,
but (mumbling)
but realizing that the job that I'm in now
is an incredible opportunity.
So I'm loving it, it's not that I hate it,
it's providing extreme value.
- I got great news for you,
you'll never know the alternative
of the one you picked.
You can't really do both.
You can flirt with both.
But you can't put your ass on two toilets.
And so, you can do things,
but if you have two businesses,
you have no businesses.
It's like having two quarterbacks.
I would tell you
an unbelievable, liberating feeling,
that so many of you are struggling with,
so many people here don't make decisions
because they're worried about the
what if of the other decision.
This is how life actually works.
You'll never know.
You will never know if you bounce now
and go on with your life solo,
or if you stay another three years.
You're just not gonna know.
So why dwell on it?
Just pick one and fucking go.
(crowd calling out)
Thank you brother.
- [Man] Give Babin some love.
("Goat Life Anthem" by Jan Ace)
You're welcome, bro.
- I tried to get one, but
you were on (mumbling).
- Thank you.
- Sorry, can I get one?
- Don't worry, don't worry.
Let's go, fast, please,
before it gets crazy.
Awesome.
- Thanks buddy.
What about your buddy here?
- One tip for all the
people starting their
social media marketing agencies?
- Work.
(mellow music)